one of the craziest Game of Thrones fan
theories claims that Daario naharis and
euron greyjoy are the same person
and it's actually kind of possible in a
Storm of Swords Daario naharis is one of
three captains of the stormcrows a
mercenary company hired by young Kai to
defend the city from Daenerys Targaryen
Daario kills the two other captains and
brings the company to Dany side helping
to take young Chi then marine Daario is
a great fighter and a great talker
arrogant swaggering and ruthless he
wears colorful tyroshi clothes with a
pointed blue beard though HBO's dario's
look nothing like this in any case Danny
falls for him and the two become lovers
in a relationship that represents the
temptation of violence and vengeance of
fire and blood Daario is always offering
to kill people for Dany like Jorah and
his daughter Laura and the great masters
he suggests sluicing her dragons on her
enemies and doing what she likes without
care for responsibility or who might get
hurt Danny is horrified by his callous
brutality calls him a monster but deep
down thinks she's a monster too Daario
is the devil on Danny's shoulder
representing her darker side so he's
central to Danny's internal conflict in
a dance with dragons throughout this
book while Danny stays to rule marine
Daario is sent off on various missions
but at the end of dance and the start of
the winds of winter Daario is a hostage
of the young ke while battle begins
between Danny's forces yunkish forces
and some unexpected visitors the
Ironborn euron greyjoy
is brother to Valen Victarion and aaron
and an uncle to asha
and Theon he's a wild scheming dangerous
man a warrior and a manipulator widely
described as mad after being exiled from
the Iron Islands for raping or seducing
Victorians third wife he spent several
years killing and pillaging across Essos
in his ship of mutes called The Silence
he claims to have been everywhere from a
shy to the ruins of Valyria and has
knowledge of magic and Dragons
apparently having captured pre and his
warlock buddies in a face for crows Iran
returns to the Iron Islands that day
after Big Brother balin 'son death
and his elected king of the islands on
the promise that he will conquer
Westeros for the Ironborn after taking
the shields he sends Victarion and the
iron fleet off to find Daenerys so urine
can marry her and capture her dragons
with the magic horn dragon binder were
led to believe that meanwhile Iran is
raiding the reach but there's good
reason not to believe that's true
cuz Euron's not that interested in the
reach he says he'd bring the Ironborn
dragons and they shout out for grapes
grapes as in the reach so his talk of
taking the reach even if conquering
Westeros might be empty words to win the
Ironborn but even if you Ron does intend
to conquer
he clearly plans to do it with dragons
so why would he attack the reach and
risk the wrath of the red wine fleet
before he has dragons there is some
raiding going on along the manda but
there's no clear evidence that iran's
are part of it it's more likely that
he's focusing on his primary goal Dany
and her dragons which were led to
believe Euron leaves in the hands of
Victarion Victarion who is dumb as a
stump is only good at fighting knows
nothing about magic or dragons hates you
Ron and plans to take Danny and her
dragons for himself why would you Ron
trust Victarion with this job here's
what might be going on Euron follows the
iron fleet to marine or gets there first
in disguise perhaps he lets Victarion
deal with the young guy he lets
victorians men below the deadly horn
which apparently kills whoever uses it
then neuron can reveal himself and take
Danny and her dragons because dragon
binder brings dragons not to whoever
blows the horn but to the horns master
Euron found the horn and is manipulating
Victarion surely making huron the horns
master so when dragon binder sounds
dragons will come to the crows i not in
the reach but in slavers Bay using
Victarion like this is exactly the sort
of deception and manipulation that we
should expect from the crows eye and
having him turn up at marine would be a
pretty awesome dramatic reveal so onto
the theory what evidence is there that
Daario and Euron are the same person
for starters they look pretty similar
they're both attractive they both have
smooth pale skin have both have beards
Daario dyed blue beard and were Hardy
Bluebeard's used as disguises they both
have blue eyes as though urine is said
to have a black eye beneath his pouch
Buuren also has blue lips from drinking
shade of the evening which could wear
off or be hidden maybe and Dario has a
gold tooth which could possibly be fake
overall they look quite similar Daario
and Euron also have very similar skills
and personalities they're both good
talkers good at convincing people
Euron talks his way onto the sea stone
chair and Daario talks his way into
Danny's bed both of which are cases of
an outsider getting into a place they
don't really belong through flattery of
the giving of gifts and overwhelming
confidence they both have a talent for
mocking and belittling people they're
both endlessly bragging in fanciful
self-aggrandizing monologues like Daario
says he would tell you the names of all
the men he is slain but before he could
finish winter would come and go and come
again Euron says he's never known to
fate has never been to his knee has
sailed to a shire by the shadow and seen
wonders and terrors beyond imagining but
beneath the bravado both men a dangerous
brutal men without conscience who kill
like it means nothing they both have a
tendency to anger and they both seem to
share an interest in dragons Euron's
endlessly talking about them and plans
to steal Danny's while Daario brings up
dragons many times for someone who only
appears in a few chapters there are
weird connections in the show too in
season 3 Daario says he refuses to pay
prostitutes which is refusing to pay the
gold price which is an Ironborn thing
also at one point Daario describes a
flower his gift to Dany as beautiful but
poisonous and we know that Hurons gifts
are poisoned but thirdly and most
maddeningly in the show Daario captures
the ships of the Meereenese Navy how
many ships you might ask
93 yogurt 93 ships that is the same
number of ships as Victorian leaves with
to go to marine in the books this is not
a coincidence right either the writers
of the show are [ __ ] with us or the
fleet of ships that Daario gives Dany in
the show are somehow equivalent to the
fleet of ships you run sands to Danny in
the
there are a bunch of different ways that
could work but either way it's a strong
connection between Daario and Euron and
there's more Daario wears tyroshi
clothes and skillfully wields a Dothraki
Iraq and a Moorish Toledo which suggests
he's pretty well-traveled we know
Euron's been all over the world and
Daario has a gift for sleeping he's able
to sleep on horseback during storms
which is the sort of skill you'd learn
spending years at sea
Daria rhetorically asks if he would
steal from Dani when neurons plan is to
steal dragons from Dani and Daario and
Euron both have lines describing men as
meat there are also symbolic connections
like Dario's mercenary company is called
the storm pros when urine is repeatedly
described as the storm and his nickname
is crows I the show changed Daria's
company to the second son's but for what
it's worth urine is literally a second
son
so Daario and Euron are similar in
appearance and personality and there are
lots of little hints at a connection
between the two nothing that proves
they're the same person but enough to
suggest that there might be something
here
so does it make sense for Dario to be a
false identity of Urim what does your
own get by pretending to be some random
cell sword well we know Euron wants to
marry Danny and take her dragons by
playing the role of Daario Euron has won
Danny's love she wants to marry him says
she'd give up a crown for him
this explains why you Ron is so
confident that Danny will marry him
which is ridiculous otherwise being
Dario also allows you Ron to get an
insider's view of the situation in
Mereen and what the deal is with the
Dragons which would all be very valuable
information to someone planning to make
a move there being Dario also works with
Iran secretly being in slavers Bay as
Dario he's a hostage of the young guy he
so he just sits tired and waits for
Victarion to use dragon bind up bringing
a dragon to BRIC Iran out of yunkish
custody so he can hop on the dragon
maybe kill Victarion while he waits for
Danny to return to marine on Dragon so
you ron can feel like hey it's Sammy
Dario yo dragon seems to like me for
some reason want to go spread some fire
and blood up in these slavers admittedly
assuming a false identity on the other
side of the world might not be the best
way to achieve all this but it could
make some kind of sense to a mind like
Hurons maybe does Dario eagles Euron fit
with what we know of Dario well we don't
know much about Dario in the show he
says he's the son of the prostitute and
as far as we know he has no family no
friends no gods what we do know is that
he's treacherous Dario first came to
Danny by breaking contract with young
Chi and killing his colleagues Jorah
warns Danny that Dario is not worthy of
trust but even his beard wears false
colors danny rejects this saying jurors
just jealously pushing men away from her
which is probably partly true but in
arguing that jurors warnings are wrong
she lists them P appraisal aia za rosa
schema Belleville so bracket austin an
assassin thing is p at pre is a liar
Xaro is a schemer bellows is a braggart
and while Barristan is not an assassin
he does to save Danny as Danny later
admits Jorah always gives good counsel
and draws counsel is that Daario is
untrustworthy
and Berenstain agrees even Danny thinks
Dario was treacherous he might fit into
the three mounts or three betrayals she
is prophesied to suffer but the bigger
issue here is that Dario doesn't make
sense as a person were meant to believe
that Dario is this battle-hardened
self-serving mercenary who sides with
whoever is going to win so why is he
sticking with Dani when she's surrounded
by enemies and disease and ruin and
other cells Lords are abandoning her
everyone seems to expect Dario to betray
her even Dani herself like seriously
look at how many times Danny thinks that
Daria will betray her why doesn't he
Dario claims that he loves Dani but even
Dani doesn't believe that she says Dario
is only interested in her because she's
a dragon queen Dario wants Daenerys for
her power and her dragons and well we do
know someone else who wants to get into
Danny's pants for a power and her
dragons don't we someone else who is
treacherous dangerous giftgiving
sweet-talking smooth-skinned and
blue-eyed of the storm and all of the
crow urine gradually and Daario naharis
are very similar and being Daario could
help huron and the character of Daario
doesn't make a lot of sense on his own
Daario equals Euron actually seems
pretty believable but let's address the
elephant in the room how could all this
work
how can your own and Daario be the same
person when Daario is in slavers Bay and
Euron's half a world away in the Iron
Islands thing is Daario spends most of
the dance with dragons away from marine
and we only actually see her on a few
times in a face to the crows we don't
know exactly how the timings of these
two books line up but based on the best
guesses we have private majors timeline
and the boiled leather merchants reading
order we can get a rough idea of how
they fit together at the start of a
feast for crows iran has recently
returned to the iron islands and he
stays there until the Kingsmoot in the
drowned man at this same time in a dance
with dragons Daario is away on a mission
to ally with the Lazzarini
and dani notices he's been away for a
worryingly long time by the way daria
was given gold and treasure to give the
Lazar rain and the Kings note that
follows urine gives a puncher
gold and treasure to the Ironborn funny
coincidence right so Dario gets back to
marine after the Kings mood but he only
stays long enough to have sex with Donny
before he sent away again in the same
chapter we see urine on the shields
awhile after that in the Riva and that's
the last time we see you wrong we're
then cryptically told by mokoro that
urine is coming for Danny at the same
time that Dario is sailing to Danny so
the times do seem to line up though the
absences are still kind of a problem
your on leaving the islands after the
Kingsmoot seems like a very bad idea
shouldn't he be consolidating his power
and shouldn't REO be leading the storm
crews on their missions there might be
time for both but if you're on is Dario
he's a very busy man he's also very
bloody quick it's a long trip from the
Iron Islands to marine and Euron / Dario
must have made it like four times in one
book all theatres very long book that is
actually two books there are a bunch of
reasons why this speed is not a problem
firstly Euron is a pirate king who spent
years on the sea sailing all over the
world
if anyone can sail a ship fast you're on
gradually can especially with the help
of the warlocks and wizards he's hanging
with it's hinted several times that you
Ron uses magic to sail fast
Euron mockingly implies that he can
command the winds and sail wherever he
likes and never be becomed a later
passage directly suggests that you're on
controls the winds with blood magic and
we know you're on ship's deck is soaked
in blood there's evidence that
Melisandre blood magic can command the
winds so why not Euron's it seems likely
that you're on is using magic to sail
fast and as best we know urine is never
in Westeros at the same time that Dario
is in marine so it does seem possible
that Euron travels between Westeros and
slavers Bay to play the role of both the
crow's eye and the storm crow but there
are still problems like if Dario is
Huron how does he keep his double
identity a secret
Jerome has a crew of mutes but Dario has
a company of mercenaries who be trusts
as far as he can spit 500 sell swords of
uncertainty who would notice that their
captain keeps going off on long voyages
rather than
doing his job and leading the company
and surely someone would notice Euron's
infamous Reaper lurking near marine or
reading for supplies along the way
however the logistics work there are
lots of problems like this that make it
very hard to believe that Dario Eagles
Euron could be kept secret so where does
this leave us there are lots of little
connections and similarities between
urine and Dario
being Dario probably could fit into
Iran's plan and it would explain what
Dario's deal is it does seem possible
that Iran could travel the world fast
enough to play both parts but it's hard
to see how he could keep it secret so
based on what we know Dario equals Iran
does seem possible but there's a simpler
explanation Dario and Iran are similar
because they represent similar ideas of
violence and self-interest and their
conflict with compassion and honor and
doing the right thing which a song of us
in fire is all about every character
falls somewhere between two extremes so
in a world with thousands of characters
we can't assume that every suspicious
similarity hides a secret identity so
Euron's plan can still work fine without
him being Dario and Dario might have his
reasons for sticking with Danny maybe he
really does love her in some way well
maybe he's got something else going on
that we'll find out about later so as
much as we'd all like to see Dario with
an eyepatch bursting out of yunkish
custody on the back of a girl
high-fiving Danny on Dragon as they fly
off to spread fire and blood across
slavers Bay the most reasonable
conclusion is that Daario and Euron are
probably not the same person but it's
still fun to think about
there are links to the timeline and the
merged reading order in the description
if you want to check those out if you're
not already aware the Song of Ice and
Fire subreddit and Westeros dot org are
really cool places to discuss the Song
of Ice and Fire is where most of these
fan theories originate so you should
definitely have a look if you haven't
already thanks for watching